Configuration is also
connected to classification.
In case of classification, you establish
and then define, establish and
then define.
In case of configuration,
you're going to extension the plan,
assign the values to the variables,
refine and expand.
Extension the plan, assign values to
the variables, refine and expand.
Second configuration leverages
classification's notion of prototypical
concepts.
So the hierarchy of plans
is organized around these
prototypical notions of
a components of a chair.
A chair typically consists of legs, and
seats, and arms, and back, and so on.
The ranges of values that these
variables can take are also part of
a prototypical knowledge of
various components of a chair.
In fact they are part of the default
value of this particular component.
Clearly there are also differences
between classification and
configuration.
We use classification to make
sense of the world by mapping
combinations of precepts
into equivalence classes.
We use configuration to act on
the world by designing actions.
>> So it sounds to me like while
classification is a way of making sense
of the world, configuration is
a way of creating the world.
With classification, we perceive
certain details in the world and
decide what they are.
With configuration,
we're given something to create and
we decide on those individual variables.